I feel like my heart's racing I let her
Kim Hood describe I'm Lauren I'm Liz and
today we're gonna step inside North
Korea we just got to Seoul and we're
about to get on this tour of us that's
gonna take us all the way to the joint
security area and actually get to step
inside North Korea North Korea has been
in a political spotlight so I think like
getting to visit the border it's gonna
be super i opening i just can't believe
we're gonna go see this land that like
nobody gets to see really and this is
where we're getting picked up
everything's kinda confusing we have to
find out where we're meeting our people
do they just know we want to go cuz
we're like we look confused yeah we
finally figure it out and we all end up
getting on this bus so our tour guides
name is Skye and she's hilarious I'm
obsessed with her she said there may be
awards we have Americans Japanese and
Chinese and if we speak too loud yeah
yeah we sorry only alone yeah if you
interfere that there's a chance end of
the tour we could have a wall so right
now we're at the first stop which is the
Peace Park there's all these like
ribbons all over this fence that are and
for wishes of peace we just walked
across the freedom bridge but there's
like a gate that stops you at this other
end
[Music]
I'm in the middle of eating lunch and I
noticed that lauren hasn't gone a really
long time all of a sudden I get a text
from her that says come outside right
now because apparently there's puppies I
like puppies puppies it was a nice
little experience before a very tense
moment in our lives so we get back on
the bus for about another 30 minutes and
they say all right we are arriving at
the JSA like they're starting to get
more and more intense as soon as we got
to the first checkpoint they've got
really really strict about us not being
able to take photos if we make some
sudden movement that the North Korean
soldiers got offended by it's possible
that we could be used in propaganda
video in North Korea and then they make
a sign this really intense waiver that
says they're not responsible for our
death I'm like honestly feeling pretty
time like this is Mart move I'm not so
sure
yeah me like it's so crazy
really I was too scared to move my body
yeah and I'm just standing there
thinking don't do anything dumb Lauren
don't do anything dumb
[Music]
and the whisper
where we can I feel like my heart's
racing
it's just crazy it's yeah I would hurry
I just cried we had to walk up in two
lines like this I can't show that sorry
so then it's time for all of us to file
inside so we get at once again in a
single-file line
and we walk into the first like blue
house that we see the guard says that
everything is being monitored and it's
under surveillance 24/7 by these little
microphones that are on the desk what
was crazy is that when we looked outside
the window we actually saw the North and
South Korean border
[Music]
my mind is just totally blown I can't
believe I'm actually here
I've seen these houses and so many
photos and documentaries so we basically
just walked back and forth between South
Korea for like the three minutes that we
had time for yeah I'm like North Korea
South Korea Korea that's the JSA jyg
it's incredible actually getting to step
foot inside of a country that like I've
heard so much about and you read so much
about on the news and to actually be
there and feel it and feel that tension
is just like nothing I've ever
experienced before it's just like a
crazy thing to actually experience it
and you really could feel the tension
now that it's done and we're coming back
like the guard is making jokes we're all
super chill we're allowed to take photos
where we weren't before and it feels
like we just kind of overcame something
I do feel like we made it there in that
my heart is beating
[Music]
I'm afraid I'm gonna do something wrong
at one point I like gave the thumbs up
that's like oh no my thumbs up is feel
like start a world war